welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is artist Butterfield the John em shift
professor of English and professor of
French and music at Yale she specializes
on the works of Chaucer literature's of
France and England from the 13th to 15th
centuries and on medieval music as well
as on theories and histories of language
form and genre city writing and
bilingualism and medieval linguistic
identities
professor Butterfield's books include
the familiar enemy Chaucer language and
the nation in the Hundred Years War and
poetry and music in medieval France she
edited Chaucer and the city a collection
of essays she also co-founded the
medieval song network a collaborative
international project to encourage new
interdisciplinary research on the
medieval lyric today we talk with
professor Butterfield about medieval
English lyrics and Chaucer
welcome professor Butterfield thank you
very much thank you the invitation you
are a very busy woman you're currently
working on three book projects one is a
new edition of medieval English lyrics
for Norton the second is a book on lyric
and form and then lastly of course your
biography of Chaucer so why don't you
give us a little bit of an overview of
each of them okay well the two lyric
projects are related in the sense that
I'm working on an edition of medieval
English lyrics and then in writing the
book about lyric that comes out of the
research that I'm doing for that that's
the theory it's in practice quite hard
to write a book and an additional at
once and then the biography is something
I was commissioned to do a long time ago
in fact and I've been working away at it
off and on wondering how to write a
biography of a medieval author and so
that project is sort of ticking away
gradually happening gradually seeing the
lights okay I am curious as to what led
you to be interested in this line of
work well I have always been interested
in writing in lyric in literature and in
music and I suppose I took a turn as a
graduate student and went deep into
French literature of the Middle Ages and
then as it were came back to England a
little bit later although I was teaching
in English literature all the way
through so I had been fascinated by the
links between England and France in the
Middle Ages I've also been fascinated by
the links between poetry music in the
Middle Ages so that's there's a
continuity in the kinds of interests
that I have okay and what exactly is a
lyric I mean versus a poem versus a song
are they all the same thing that's such
a good question it's actually very hard
to be hard and fast about these things
in fact many people would argue right
now it's very interesting how people are
rethinking what we mean by lyric right
now and many people are arguing that our
notions of lyric currently are very much
formed from the Romantic period and
later but that these are attitudes
towards poetry that we're really in some
ways invented by literary criticism
because when you go back through the
centuries you find that people are much
less anxious about what lyric might be
yes if there's music then it's a song
but we like to think of lyric now as
being something much more specific we
think of it as being to do with love to
do with personal emotion all sorts of
personal anguish that comes to the
surface okay and you did bring one with
you today would you like to read it for
us well one of the things I'm really
interested in in the Middle Ages is
whether we really want to use this word
lyric but also whether the kinds of
short bursts that people used and wrote
and composed and listened to were the
same as as as ones that we listen to now
and I just thought I'd read out to a
couple I'm not going to sing any I'm
afraid well are they normally sang well
there's definitely on the continent that
huge numbers survived with music in
England sadly most of the music has
disappeared so just a handful that are
left with music but this is one you see
that I think might sound MIT to many
people as very modern and it goes
Western wind when will doubt blow the
small rain down can rain Christ if my
lover in my arms
and I in my bed again and that's that's
a 15th century text it's probably
earlier than that and that's the rise of
music but in a very religious setting
interestingly there's another one which
is a lullaby just to give you some at
some idea of it which is just lullaby la
la la a little child why weepest thou so
saw and then that little refrain comes
up many many times across different
texts with different sorts of words
added to it and so there's a very fluid
sort of combination of different sorts
of texts and melodies that that float
around in the culture so now did anyone
write lyrics or yes everyone could have
written them it was it's right one of
the things about the Middle Ages is that
so much that's come down to us is
anonymous we've lost all track of who
wrote things there are some big author
figures there is a course Geoffrey
Chaucer that I expect many people know
but he was relatively late in the period
and there are some other named figures
but in general we have thousands of
examples of short bursts with no
specific name attached to them that we
can now discover what's interesting is
that yes I mean people presumably were
composing and producing songs and short
short verse all over the place which has
not been written down so we always have
to remember that there's a vast amount
that was in oral circulation and what we
have in writing was just really the tip
of the iceberg so given that lyrics were
oral and but of course some of them were
also written down how do you go about
doing the research for the books that
you're working on well it's it's quite
hard work in the sense that especially
in England there
many many manuscripts of very varied
types in which short burst gets copied
and although some most of it has been
catalogued not all of it has and if it
has been catalogued it only in quite
brief terms so you actually have to go
and spend a lot of time which I love
working with medieval manuscripts most
of these are in Oxford and London and
Cambridge and trying to locate the short
verse identify it copy it down and
understand its context and one of the
interesting things that really
fascinates me about the period
especially in England is that their
expression in English are very often
copied with material in French and Latin
and they're not until much later in the
period copied together collected so
there isn't really such thing as a lyric
anthology until the 14th century by and
large and so you have to sort of dig
around and find things and find there
may be quite a lot of lyrics and more
manuscript they won't necessarily be
grouped as types so that's something
that you that you know adds to the
pleasure of the hunt it's interesting to
me to go back to that time period and
have these lyrics being written and sung
and when you say there's music with them
when they're copied out and are they
typically copied out in English even
though Latin and French was the
languages of the the literary day in
England yes well that's right one of the
things we observe is that more and more
lyrics get copied in English so to begin
with it's very rare to find lyrics in
English okay in the 30th century there
very few relatively speaking far more in
French and Latin okay but that as time
goes on and English asserts itself more
as a literary language then people are
more comfortable copying things down in
English but it's true that that's what
really one reason why there's quite a
it's quite an effort to locate English
words in if you like in a sea of frat
French and Latin now in terms of the
muse
how how does it accompany the lyric is
it written out in musical form and then
someone would have to have musical
knowledge to do that you're quite right
music the ability to write down music
has always been a specialist active it
today and even now not everybody can do
it and so the people who are writing the
music in the Middle Ages were trained
literate usually clerics of some kind so
but it's interesting because what the
clerics are used to doing is copying
religious material the mass liturgy and
that music in Latin so they're having to
think harder about how to actually copy
something that has very different sorts
of words and fun and a function that may
not be immediately apparent to them so
often the music is a little bit more
scrappy than in there it's certainly in
the big big books and some of it is very
funny actually there's a fifteen century
book that I'm very fond of just probably
owned by a student in Oxford who was
acquire a chorister and his book is
wonderfully messy it's a complete mess
of information of all kinds science and
literature and law and he has about 20
songs copied many of them very erotic
very obscene with little bits of music
here and there so that that's an example
of a book that's quite late in the
period that I'm working with that isn't
actually very easy to work with because
it's in such a state I am still curious
though about people writing lyrics these
lyrics and then did they have to go to
yet another person to help them work out
the musical aspects of it well one of
the things that we often conclude is
that people don't write down the music
so that someone else can read or perform
from it often the writing down of the
music is a way of recording that song in
some way for posterity if you like or in
some way for for someone else to use but
there isn't always a direct relationship
between I'm going to copy this down
because someone wants to sing it okay
people were
usually had the facility of their
memories far more than we do now because
they had to there were fewer books
people were able to access so I think
the world of oral composition and oral
performance was a very very large part
of people's lives and the writing down
was a relatively small part of what
people are up to again these things
change and you have to be very alert to
the period to understand the right kind
of context to assume now are there any
rules when it comes to where if I mean
you know for instance I think of haiku
and there's very definite rules that go
along with that is is it similar for the
lyric or no that's also a really good
question because in some ways there are
certainly rules for French and Latin
composition no one even thought of right
of having rules for composition in
English until much much later there
wasn't even a grammar for English until
the 17th century really people assumed
that if you wanted to treat a language
seriously that English wasn't an
appropriate language to do that with so
it's an interesting question that in
some ways I'm really researching I'm
trying to understand when people write
births what kinds of principles they had
in mind because there's so much variety
there's a huge amount of variety and
some of it to be honest looks to us
again quite scrappy unformed the the
kind of material where you could go on
and on and it wouldn't really matter
where you stopped and so much of it is
interpolated and chopped about and
reinserted in different contexts that
again this notion that a song had to
have a kind of pure organic form doesn't
seem to be uppermost in in people's
minds at least in many cases okay
I am curious also about when these
lyrics were being written how they were
used in everyday life well we have so
little evidence to go on really we have
more evidence from the later of the
period
and it does seem as if people in in the
15th century for example is a wonderful
stack of letters where clearly people
exchanged lyrics as as love lyrics do
but in the way that we think people like
people might do in later periods and and
people do now the more sentimental of us
so the that there is that tradition
there is very much tradition of
exchanging if you like a kind of
language of love that will that will
appeal not just to the woman or to the
man of your of your dreams but really to
your social peers too to make you look
like someone who is very literate tune
articulate and able to compose in this
sort of elegant style but many lyrics
have a devotional function and in a way
this is the primary it's sort of
difference between the middle ages and
our own perhaps that people wrote verse
to concentrate on being able to
contemplate their crucifixion different
stages of the church year they wrote
many pieces of short bursts of the
Virgin they this is part of a way of
focusing their minds on the important
eternal matters of life and death
and to put away earthly concerns there
are many lyrics about death there are
many lyrics reminding one that that
death is inevitable and that one must
get oneself in order morally and
spiritually for that reason alright
let's move to your work on Chaucer whom
many people know him primarily for the
canterbury tales although he is a very
interesting man and that he's had he has
a wide range of interest from you know
alchemy to philosophy to astronomy even
and you are writing a biography on him
so they'll tell us a little bit about
that process and how are you doing the
research around it yes one of the Djoser
is a great poet and that's how we think
of him now ironically this is well known
to jalsa scholars that there's quite a
fat book of documents that survived
about him not a single one mentions him
as a writer not a single one so if you
only had that bunch of documents you
would have no actual evidence that
Chaucer was the poet that we know now we
have other reasons of course for
assigning all this poetry to him so it
is a real puzzle for a biographer or at
least a very different kind of project
from writing a biography of someone much
more recent for whom thousands of
letters might survive and reminiscences
and and people able to talk about this
person we have nothing like that for
Chaucer so that this is both a challenge
and and a problem if you like but one at
one of the ways in which I have tackled
this is to very much think of Chaucer in
his location in London and when I
started this book biography I was
teaching and living in London and it was
a matter for me of daily life to walk
past parts of the river that Chaucer
would have known or stand in locations
where we know he he lived
of course modern London has a [ __ ] is
transformed from its medieval past and
there was a great fire in in the 17th
century that destroyed many many many
buildings but nonetheless it's a
location that is full of history and
certain aspects and views are the same
and we have Westminster Abbey amongst
other many sort of corners of the many
were past lurking in the modern city so
one of the things I'm trying to do is
really use the cities as a as a way of
thinking about the imaginative process
in Chaucer and trying to understand how
he saw things how he was stimulated by
the locations in which he worked the
streets down which he walked
and I'm also interested in very much in
the river because the River Thames was a
great thoroughfare in the Middle Ages
it's becoming more of that now in modern
London again it's a great underused
resource if you like for travel and in
the Middle Ages people went up and down
it's thick with boats so one of the ways
I'm really thinking about the biography
is through the River Thames through its
actual capacity to transport people
around the city but also it's symbolic
and imaginative capacity to create a
sort of picture of how people and how
Chaucer in particular took elements from
life and transformed them through his
imagination into poetry I have read and
I I could be incorrect that Chaucer was
was very helpful and having more lyrics
written in English is that true or no
yes Chaucer was interesting because he
wrote in English he was the first poet
well he's a he's an unusual case in
every respect
but so he wrote entirely it seems
exclusively an initial that that's the
only language in which his pertree
survives we it's quite likely wrote some
in French as well but they haven't
survived whereas his contemporaries
wrote in Latin and French as well
Chaucer clearly made a decision to write
in English
the reason therefore is that he he was
deeply influential on English poetry of
her afterwards and so we have a lot of
writing that's that's clearly been
written because Josie wrote anything at
all in English was very instrumental in
getting lyrics written more and more in
English versus Latin or French one of
the things that's remarkable though
about Jolson is a kind of paradox is
that he writes in English but he writes
through so often through French poetry
literally absolutely new new thoroughly
and there's a funny kind of way in which
his his writing is more French than
English though it happens to be written
in English and the French poetry of the
time
the it was the dominant aesthetic
cultural language and culture of the
time and so in some ways Chaucer was the
mediator of that vitally important
culture into the English language it was
already an important aspect of English
life you know the the aristocracy had
been marrying into French in France
throughout their throughout centuries
and Chaucer's in in Chaucer's own
lifetime ed of the 3rd and Richard the
second were themselves thoroughly
continental monarchs and richard ii was
brought up in france and had a french
mother and would have spoken french his
mother tongue almost certainly so there
there is a huge context in england for
welcoming understanding being utterly
familiar with French culture and
Chaucer's role if you like was was to
just tip that into English very good
well thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work okay thank you so much for inviting
me for more information about professor
Butterfield and her research please
visit our website at Yale that edu slash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale that is fascinating